la guerra en Siria ha entrado en su
décimo tercer año y hay una generación
entera de niños y jóvenes que solo han
visto la guerra o les ha tocado vivir
como refugiados en los países vecinos de
la región estamos hablando de millones
de niños sirios cuya infancia se ha
visto truncada por el conflicto y las
secuelas de la guerra marcarán Su futuro
si bien el régimen de avasal ha
recuperado prácticamente el control de
todo el país a excepción de la región de
itley donde todavía está bajo control de
las facciones rebeldes el retorno de los
refugiados no está contemplado para
poder regresar a salvo es necesaria una
reconstrucción el país está devastado
después de más de una década de guerra y
violencia y hay una fuerte crisis
humanitaria que se ha grabado todavía
más con los terremotos recientes en el
norte de Siria y el sur de Turquía aquí
en el Líbano hemos visto como familias
de refugiados han decidido regresar a
sus ciudades natales pero después de
poco tiempo han vuelto al Líbano porque
se sienten más desprotegidos allí que
los campamentos el Líbano enfrenta la
mayor crisis económica de las últimas
décadas y no puede con la sobrecarga de
los refugiados cuando ahora además las
ayudas humanitarias son mucho más
limitadas esto les ha dejado en una
situación de extrema vulnerabilidad
obligándoles a tener que mendigar a las
calles o a ser Víctimas de los
matrimonios forzosos